[car tires]
When you found out
you'd been hired by GE,
what was your reaction?
I didn't believe it at first.
It really didn't sink in until
I got the first paycheck.
And I thought, I'm
really in here.
And you'd walk across
the parking lot
and look all the
way down the avenue
at all these antique,
100-year-old buildings.
And it really felt like you
were part of something then.
What Kevin Green
has been a part of
is an iconic company
that has built
the majority of North America's
locomotives for over a century.
Without these massive
machines pulling freight
around the country, the
explosion of American industry
would have stopped
in its tracks.
Kevin's married, no kids.
And he's been working as a
machinist at GE for 15 years
now.
We'd always had ups and downs
in the locomotive business.
There was layoffs sometimes.
But then, they would
call people back.
But this time, it really looks
like it's going downhill,
and it's not going
to come back up.
[train whistle]
This one was
made in about '47.
And that little tin railroad
station was built here in Erie.
Kevin's friend, Donnie
Rhodes, also works at the plant.
After working all day
in the din of a factory,
the wheels on the rails here
kind of helps you unwind.
But the threat of
more layoffs makes
it almost impossible to unwind.
Last summer, their close friend
Denny died of a heart attack
after he got laid off from GE.
And you have to think that
the stress of not knowing what
you're going to do, and
where the good paychecks are
going to come from, that had
to be a contributing factor.
I don't think they give
one whit about the worker.
I don't think they give one
whit about the community
that the workers are in.
I mean, it's just demoralizing.
I don't see any happy ending.
Well, what are
you going to do?
I'm going to go to
school and take up
a degree in
international business,
because if you can't beat them,
you might as well join them.
Things are more
complicated for Kevin.
I don't think I could
pass a test right now.
My concentration is zilch.
He's been diagnosed with a
severe case of Lyme disease
that's been expensive to treat.
I had no idea there
was anything in the world
besides dementia or
Alzheimer's or something
that could do this to a person.
So let's say, Kevin, you lose
your job, your Lyme disease
gets worse.
What are you going to do?
I don't know.
I do not know.
It's looming.
You know it's common.
You're going to get the
tap on the shoulder,
but you don't know when.
That must be really stressful.
It is.
[car tires]
It is damn cold here, Scott.
Do you ever get used to this?
Actually, this is about as
warm as I dress in the winter.
Really?
Yeah, it's not bad.
Scott Lawson is president of
the local union representing
GE workers like Kevin.
The famous Dionr with an O.
Dinor with an O?
Yes.
This is the only area in
the world you'll see this.
Yeah.
In GE's heyday, they had
as many as 22,000 people
working inside those gates.
And today, there's
less than 3,000.
It's just a constant bleed of
employees out of this plant.
Some jobs have been
lost to automation, others
to globalization.
But in recent
years, they've been
lost to the Lone Star State.
Lured by huge tax breaks,
GE built a locomotive plant
in Fort Worth that's nonunion.
And workers there are paid less.
We watched,
basically, good jobs
being ripped out
of Pennsylvania,
given to the state of Texas.
And you're talking a
multibillion dollar
corporation that really
doesn't need the tax breaks.
These decisions affect
the entire community.
An estimated 1 in 11
jobs in Erie County
depend on the plant.
There's a lot of
fabrication shops
and electrical shops that
do a lot of work for us.
So it has a huge
ripple effect.
It's a massive ripple effect.
GE insists it's laying off
workers to stay competitive,
especially as
countries like China
take a bigger share
of the market.
When you have a business
that's running at 25% profits,
it's hard to tell the employees,
we need more money out
of your pocket,
because we're not
going to be able to pay the
dividend to the shareholders.
And GE is not the only one.
You have a lot of companies
that are this way.
It's not about competitiveness.
It's about union busting
Scott believes the
decline of unions
is a big part of the problem.
50 years ago, a third of the
US workforce was unionized.
We'll stand up and fight back.
[cheering]
It's down to 11% today.
And the gulf between the
rich and everyone else
is now wider than ever before.
Now, let's see if we can't
get you out of that truck
and back in the plant, buddy.
But Scott's members
make 2 and 1/2 times more
than the average
salary here in Erie,
about $70,000 plus benefits.
There is an argument
that global competition
has put a lot of pressure
on these corporations--
Sure.
--and that unions
got too powerful.
They got too greedy,
and they got lazy.
What's your reaction
when people say,
you guys make too much an hour?
What do you do for a living?
That's what I ask them.
We handcraft a 460,000
pound locomotive.
And there's a lot of pride
in building something
that you know is going to run
for 20 years pulling freight
across the United States.
And when you lose
that sense of pride,
sometimes you lose
a sense of purpose.
And that's what we're seeing.
A lot of people turn
to drugs and alcohol.
And some just say,
I've had enough.
And kill themselves.
Sure.
We've had quite a few suicides
just from our workers.
It was 7:00 o'clock
on a Friday night.
It was the middle of the shift.
And we were working.
And the machine I was on
faced this fellow's machine.
I looked over where
he was working,
and he was handing on the crane.
He had a choker around his neck.
His knees were bent.
And he was not moving.
And he was about as white as
your paper on the counter.
And I couldn't believe
what I was looking at.
In 2017, Erie's suicide
rate reached an all time high,
the average victim, a
47-year-old white male.
But the problem isn't
unique to this city.
A recent study revealed a
shocking spike in the death
rate for middle-aged
white working class
Americans, caused by alcoholism,
drug overdoses, and suicides.
I think a lot of people
are feeling that despair,
especially if you
had a lucrative job,
and you're facing a
change where you're going
to go back to
living hand-to-mouth
like you were before.
They don't know what
the future holds.
I don't know what
it holds, either.
But I'm going to find out.